let's talk about moon base eight i've
watched all the episodes
i love the show it's fantastic um i told
you this before we started but i watched
them all and then my son wanted to see
it so i re-watched them with my son
who also loved it so i've seen him twice
awesome it's a great
it's a really great show thank you thank
you he's gonna start asking for beef
style stew now
i know well this is a thing it's it's
such a great idea and
the funny thing is that you made this
show
you and uh and fred armisen
and tim heideker you guys made this show
before
the pandemic but it's such a pandemic
show because it's about these guys
who are training to maybe go to the moon
someday
in the middle of this arizona you know
desert
in this little fake environment and you
guys
are sort of quarantined together yeah i
mean that's kind of there actually is an
episode
called quarantine called quarantine and
you made all of this before
the pandemic but it's sort of this
perfect show for
for right now yeah i you know people
used to say to me when i was young when
i would get lucky they're like
riley you're born with a horseshoe up
your ass like
like i don't know if you've ever heard
that expression i have not it means
you're very lucky you know like
and uh oh if only i had a horseshoe in
my ass
oh to be that lucky can we swear on here
now bob yeah sure yeah really we're free
of the constraints
yes yeah all right hey um
that's coming out okay uh yeah we made
the show
we we uh we
fred and tim and i and also john
chrysler who did baskets and has worked
with generic a bunch in the past
and did portlandia and the four of us
really put the show
together but the initial instinct was
the me tim and fred wanted to just
spend a lot of time together and find a
project where we could
you know just goof off and be confined
to the same why would three men
be confined to the same space we're like
prison the army
too expensive oh i know and i remember
there was these weird
experiments that they're doing right now
there's in utah there's one
in hawaii there's one where they're
practicing
uh being colonists on mars
and the moon like you can't just like
send a bunch of guys up there and hope
they figure it out you know
you have to train and train and train
and figure out techniques and protocols
and
so i thought that would be perfect and
then it
it kind of started on a text chain and
and one by one we just built
these ideas and these characters and
then we thought well if we can get
someone to pay for all these episodes
we should make it and a24 just amazingly
stepped in and let us make
all six and it's it hasn't been market
tested
it hasn't been you know gone through the
development process with
executives right right anything like
that so it's this weird kind of handmade
uh sweet show that really just reflects
our sense of humor and
i'm i'm really i feel incredibly
grateful
that this thing that we took this risk
on
like it took a second actually to sell
the show you know we made it
and then most um like the big
players that put shows out they don't
really work like that you know they
like to have a hand in the beginning of
the project so
it took a second and then showtime was
like yeah we'll take it
and then it just timed out perfectly
suddenly shotan was like
oh my god we've got a golden egg you
know
the world has come around to like mirror
the show
um anyway and another reason i think
especially right now
specifically this weekend which none of
us could have predicted
how this weekend would feel but the show
has a kind of a political yes just goofy
humor you know no people are ready for i
think
people are everybody is burnt out
and exhausted by what's been going on in
our national discourse and then so this
show about these three
i don't want to call them idiots they
are idiots but they are idiots uh
these three idiots who are on a moon
base and uh
and and and or a practicing to maybe go
to the moon
and none of them are qualified to ever
go to the moon maybe fred armstrong's
character but really
live a couple things the possible
eligibility
yes yeah but it's really uh it's really
it's funny but it's also
sweet and uh i the fact that i loved
watching it with my 15 year old son and
we were both howling at the same stuff i
mean that's
that's a good sign that's a really
that's a real gift right now we have a
clip here do you know what the clip is
well in this episode our characters have
have had a very dispiriting in kind of
like
self-esteem busting interaction with a
spacex
crew it's really funny the spacex base
turns out we didn't realize it is
nearby in the desert we see them one day
with these binoculars setting up
and we reach out to them and we
quickly realized like wow they're a lot
sexier than us
they're much better funded it's all elon
musk
and uh they have like street taco
tuesday you're like eating freeze-dried
sweet potato soup and they're having
like taco tuesdays at their base
so anyway we have this really kind of
discouraging for us
day with them and at the end of it all
i challenge one of them to a foot race
that that
i sadly do not win uh played by my good
friend thomas mann he's
really great in that but um anyway at
the end of it
the guys are trying to make me feel
better like fred armstrong says like you
know that
i think that guy cheated and my response
to to him trying to buck me up is this
let's take a look you know kappa i think
that guy got the jump on you
wish he had an instant replay camera
don't you get it we did win
i'm proud of you guys you showed up
today
you made this place look like a dazzling
wonder
yeah and those kids those kids are sweet
they're dreamers right they think
they're going to mars
really really that program's prepared to
go to mars
in their lifetime i don't think so nah
maybe in their grandchildren's lifetime
they're going to mars but those people
are not going to mars
nope us
we're going to the moon yeah yeah we are
we are going to the moon yes you get it
yeah you get it and when i get up there
yeah i'm gonna look down at them
and i'm gonna flip them the bird tell
you i'm gonna flip them to birds so bad
their heads will spin that's it there's
more moon man yeah we're going there
three cheers for robert caputo hip hip
hop
hip hip all right hip hip hooray
take your boots off before you go up on
the table though well
can you just have his moment here give
me a hand down you can go back up just
take your boots off
uh all right well the uh the show is
absolutely hilarious it's
moon base eight and it uh airs
sundays at 11 p.m on showtime and it
really is
the perfect show for right now and uh
a great show anyway but for right now i
really encourage people to
to check it out i cannot thank you
enough i mean
i talked to you for so long i don't know
that we're going to have any other show
today
because i was so happy to see you in
person
it's just a real joy i'm really thrilled
to be back here with you again
you guys were one of the first people
that took a shot at me and let me be on
tv in this kind of
circumstance so i'm i'm i'll always be
grateful to you conan how cool
and i appreciate what you're giving
people right now too while we're all
stuck at home
yeah well listen uh anytime john c
reilly class act
and uh and make sure you check out uh
moon base eight you will not be sorry
it's really fantastic